hello I'm Tess Lynch and today we're
going to be talking about Marjory
Stoneman Douglas listen I'm gonna
transport you back in time picture it
Florida the 1920s there's a special
place that is the craziest environment
that you can find called
the Everglades but South Florida is
experiencing an unprecedented population
explosion so they're draining wetlands
building houses the developers really
great I'm gonna build Hey look at this
swamp it's full of I'm gonna
put them in 99-cent store on it
but the problem with this is that
everybody's draining the resources of
one of the most unique ecosystems on the
planet the Everglades and Ernest Coe a
landscape architect realizes like this
place is special as hell I'm gonna get
this place certified as a national
bargain with lousy idea
and so he's flipping through the the
important people of Florida directory
and he comes across named Marjory
Stoneman Douglas
she's very interesting lady she's like
you know I'm very early supporter of the
ACLU and I'm supporting you know when
women's suffrage and civil rights that's
just what I do I'm opinionated and cause
like this is the perfect person to get
on board with my cause and Cole is like
come with me to the Everglades and so
she goes out of the Everglades and she's
all her pearls and she's wearing her
straw hat
she's like yikes this place is too muggy
too buggy to inhospitable it's muggy and
gucky I don't like it and
she'sa your ice cream holy that's
the crocodile hold hands with alligators
what that is there's a manatee anything
look like a cow under the ocean floor
that money grow tree that's grown to the
brand-new artists have salt half fresh I
don't know how that thing girls but it's
been doing it I actually think I love
this place I'm gonna be a champion for
here there's a bug in front of me what
you see that bug I see you see the virus
she the I love bugs but that bug I
don't like it's like he's like
antagonistic he's there I could grab him
but I don't want to kill him I just want
to release him to nature you know what I
mean well slice I'll make you going so
they go to these town hall meetings and
the developers are like moles moles
moles CO and Marjorie are like shut the
up
protect the Everglades and the
legislators are like alright but I mean
it's not gonna be so simple as like
kosis Marjorie I think they're saying
that this land is pretty much protected
and marshes Lee don't you know the
government by now it's gonna be a
long-fought battle co so Marjorie goes
down into the Everglades and she spends
13 crazy long years writing every detail
y'alright book the Everglades river of
grass that's a good title goddammit 1947
this thing is published immediate
bestseller so people are like I
was just sort of thinking about my
casseroles now I'm an activist where all
of a sudden the Everglades are really
important to people who never cared
before and then later that year the
first 1.3 million acres of the
Everglades are officially designated
designated designated as a national work
just like Coe and Marjorie had wanted
but then Ernest Coe died soon
it's so sad most people could kind of
kick back guess what she doesn't quit
you know why girl likes a challenge so
when she hears the Nixon administration
is planning to build Miami Nash
International Airport on the Everglades
she just can't let it
would you mind if I make your drink just
a little higher is that okay you're
simply in that test this is a very small
wineglass yeah they catch up on you
there let me know now cool so what is
she does Marjory Stoneman Douglas meets
the Nixon administration on the runway
and they're like such a pebble in my
shoe she's a nuisance she won't budge
and Nixon's like fine we'll build it
somewhere else
I'll see you next time bozos and she
skips away how can you argue with
someone who's like don't destroy nature
how can you so Marjorie is looking back
at what she's done and she's like holy
cow it's the third largest National Park
and that's nothing to shrug it I'll just
keep going till I die and she does in
1998 at the age of a hundred and eight
he Everglades for a moment grows silent
and there's a manatee and he's like
there she goes
the mother of the Everglades
to quote Margery be a nuisance where it
counts be depressed discouraged and
disappointed at failure and the
disheartening effects of ignorance greed
corruption and bad politics but never
give up today the students at Marjory
Stoneman Douglas High School carry on
that idea by turning their pain into
action and they are the pebble in the
shoe they are the nuisance they are the
people who will not let something so
important be taken away there are some
things that are too special to take
[Music]
be a nuisance Cheers sweaty here in the
Everglades various way
[Music]
you